okay so the suicide squad in my opinion
is one of the best dceu films out there
it's everything that i wanted from a
movie centered around task force x
and in the film i feel there's one scene
that is absolutely perfect in its
handling of metaphor and meaning
this is the scene at the end in which
rat catcher 2 summons a legion of rats
in order to take down star of the
conqueror when i first saw this moment
in the cinema i was absolutely blown
away
by not only the action but also the
cameo music and message
i'm a bit ashamed to admit that i may
have may have watched it again
and that my eyes got a bit hurty from
the water coming out of them
i wasn't crying though i wasn't crying
you you were the one crying
now in skipping that in case you haven't
seen it
and are here for whatever reason let's
just set the stage for how we got to
this point
the suicide squad was sent to the island
of quarter maltese in order to take down
the tower jotunheim
which we discovered hit a dirty little
secret commissioned by the us government
this involved an alien life form known
as star of the conqueror
which had been used in human experiments
in order to see if there was a way to
create a hive mind
the squad destroyed the tower and the
starfish was freed
but rather than abandoning the island to
it they defied their orders in order to
take it down
when everything seemed lost staro
screamed this out
through one of his drones this
city is
though ratcatcher 2 backfired with one
of the most powerful lines in the entire
movie
this city isn't yours
this city isn't ours
this city is theirs from this point rat
catcher 2 brings forth her army of rats
and they swarm starro climbing inside
its eye and eating it from the inside
now not only is this a great way to take
down the beast it's also a metaphor for
unity and the squad itself
throughout the movie we followed the
downtrodden and often overlooked vermin
of the dceu
and watched as they managed to work
together to take down something far
greater than themselves
the squad aren't exactly the first
people that come to mind when we think
of superheroes
and whereas dc has been brilliant at
building gods amongst men
it's also important to remember that
they do have characters who aren't
exactly the best of the best of the best
so now for lack of a better word the
squad themselves are very much
the rats of society in fact when we are
first introduced to them
they're either trapped in cages or on
their knees scrubbing the floor and
running around with no plan beyond their
own survival the team are a complete
mess
and nowhere is this show more than the
massacre at the beach which opens the
movie
it showcases why they're terrible and
you're meant to view them as being
things that aren't worthy of life and
characters that don't really deserve to
have a movie made about them
however by the end of the film they
completely win you round and you realize
these characters are some of the most
relatable ones in a comic book movie
ever
they're perfectly built up and we have
way more in common with them
than say we do with superman this is
something that gun himself is incredible
at doing
and just in the same way that he took
the guardians and made them a-listers
the director has built up a team of
misfits and made them some of the best
characters in the dc eu
in my opinion of course now the moment
where the scene
really hits home for me is when rat
catcher remembers her father
the man she idolized and sadly lost to
drugs
though the pair had nothing they had a
community of rats
which kept them warm at night and were
very much their family
the pair were homeless and much like the
rats that they loved
overlooked in society because they
didn't fit the conventional stereotypes
of what a normal person should seek
the pair weren't materialistic or
concerned with money they just had each
other
they also appreciate the beauty in life
that one could find
looking over a city holding the person
that meant the most to them
not only is it a brilliant cameo to have
taika watiti in the film
but he also has one of the best lines in
the movie ratcatcher 2 asks him why rats
and he replies with the following rats
are the lowliest and most despised of
all creatures my love
if they have purpose
so do we all
it's such a standout thing for me that
sums up not only our own lives
but also the lives of the squad
themselves they have
up until this point pretty much being
regarded as cannon fodder
whose lives aren't important in the end
they end up defying the controller while
it has over them
in order to take down a creature who has
started to gain control over a
population
because they would rather be free than
doom humanity to a cage
this is the moment where the squad
really feel like a team to me
and working together they managed to
take down the goliath and conquer
insurmountable odds
also yeah just just the imagery of a
million rats swarming everyone
it does look pretty cool now i
absolutely love the score at this point
too
and for me it's up there with hans
zimmer's man of steel theme
for me it just drives home the emotion
the characters are feeling
and due to its empowering nature it's
hard not to well up whilst watching it
it also has a change when we enter
sorrow's eyes with holly
and the composer removes all of the
instruments except for the vocals and
belts
this adds a sense of wonder and beauty
to the destruction that we see playing
out
there's also some tragedy too as starro
says he was happy just floating in space
and staring at the stars oh so that
that's why he's a starfish however
much like the squad he was plucked out
of his home and forced to do things
against his will
in order to serve the nefarious purposes
of the u.s government
it's a bittersweet ending but it also
allows our protagonist bloodsport to
overcome his fear of rats
and in doing so he conquers his own
trauma bloodsport was abused by his
father and locked in with the creatures
which led to a lifelong phobia however
seeing the good in them makes him change
his perspective
and the way that he also views the world
he very much overcomes the odds
much like the rest of the squad and it
leads to true character growth
and also a cute very cute way to end the
film
so overall i think the scene is
absolutely outstanding from the way that
it's filmed
the score the emotion meaning and also
the cameo
it truly is a breath of fresh air that
elevates the movie
and it feels like the perfect way to
close out not only the film
but also the journey that the characters
have gone on the scene is perfect
and it tops off one of my favorite comic
book movies in recent memory
[Music]
now obviously i'd love to hear your
thoughts and if you're new here
welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host paul aka the guy whose puns
are a ratastrophe hey i hope you enjoyed
the video though yeah
bore that last line and if you did i'd
really appreciate the thumbs up
and don't forget to subscribe for videos
like this each and every day
we are running a competition right now
and giving away three mcu boxsets on the
30th of august
and all you have to do to be on the
chance of winning is like the video
make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the movie
we pick the comments at random at the
end of the month and the winners of the
last one are on screen right now
say that to you then message me on
twitter at heavyspoilers if you want
something else to watch then make sure
you check out our breakdown of the post
credits scene
which will be linked on screen right now
we've gone over the whole thing and
discussed what could be happening in
peacemaker
so it's definitely worth checking out if
you want to know more without the way
thank you for sending through the video
i've been paul i'll see you next time
take care peace
[Music]
[Music]
is